David, how likely is it that Donald Trump
will declare martial law at some point in
his presidency, either to avoid being impeached
and removed, or if he loses in 2020 to avoid
relinquishing the white house or in advance
of the 2020 election to justify not having
the election altogether?
All right, so three different scenarios where
the, this, uh, emailer wonders if Donald Trump
will apply martial law.
Declare martial law.
Here's the reality.
It's extremely unlikely.
It is extremely.
So martial law is a suspension effectively
of the normal law enforcement infrastructure
of the country replaced by the military, taking
control of domestic law enforcement.
Now, on a federal level, only the president
has the power to impose martial law.
And this all goes back to, um, uh, limitations
on martial law that exists thanks to court
decisions, which were established between
the civil war and world war II.
So for example, in 1878, Congress passed the
posse Comitatus act, which forbids military
involvement in domestic law enforcement without
congressional approval.
And that ultimately may be what is the deciding
factor here?
Even if we attribute absolutely the worst
intentions to Donald Trump, which include
that in an act of desperation where he's about
to get convicted on impeachment or he's about
to lose the election or he has lost the election
and it's almost time for him to go.
The idea is in an act of desperation, he will
declare martial law strictly speaking, you
need congressional approval in order to, uh,
declare martial law based on, uh, the posse
Comitatus act.
So I think the better question is, would Trump
try to put in place martial law?
Maybe, although I still doubt it, but if he
did, who is in control of the house and Senate
at the time and would they allow it?
And this is why, once again, you know, we
talk about the 2018 midterms and Democrats
taking over control of the house.
Now they have the investigative power of the
house.
Now we have impeachment hearings.
Now we are potentially heading in the direction
of a trial of an impeachment trial.
Uh, this is why this stuff matters.
And this is why taking over the Senate and
although it's an uphill battle in 2020 or
maybe in 2022, that's why this stuff really
matters.
I believe that there is no question Donald
Trump will make the case that because of some
unfair treatment either, uh, in the context
of the impeachment inquiry or the election
or whatever, Trump will make the case that
he didn't really lose or that someone cheated
or that this was rigged or this, that that
was regular.
The other thing, I think it is less likely
that he will actually try to declare martial
law and I think it is almost an impossibility
that he would be able to get away with it.
But things have happened for the first time
before.
I mean, think about other times martial law
has been declared in the United States is
very limited.
I think after Pearl Harbor was bombed, martial
law was declared.
Uh, and uh, if I have my history correct,
I almost don't want to say, but I think that
that was related to the internment camps of
Japanese Americans.
Um, but the instances in which martial law
was, was declared are extraordinarily limited.
And the idea that a house and Senate would
allow, particularly when not controlled by
Trump's party, that the house and Senate would
allow Trump to declare martial law because
he thinks the election against him was unfair.
Um, that the election that went against him
was unfair.
It seems extremely unlikely, but I'm willing
to have my mind changed.